[Music]
good afternoon
and good evening everyone we have people
from all over
attending this session so welcome to the
to the session
of the amazon consumer science summit
2020
virtual edition my name is mauricio
hezenje and i'll be the moderator
of this session and welcome anna no
gurney
uh thank you it's a pleasure professor
will be giving a pre-recorded talk uh
titled optimization of food supply chain
networks
why quality trade instruments and labor
all matter
so anna is a john f smith memorial
professor at the eisenberg school of
management at umass amherst
she's also director of the virtual
center for super networks
which she founded in 2001. uh she holds
a bachelor of science bachelor of arts
master of science and phd degrees from
brown university
and she's a prolific author she's
authored 14 books
written over 200 papers and also
50 over 50 book chapters
anna has been visiting scholar many
institutions around the world
and she's been recognized as a role
model for young women in stem
she in fact she was the first woman
awarded the constantine
karate atari prize by the
international society of global
optimization back last year
and only the second woman earlier this
year in the 35 history
of the of the herald
awarded this this prize
and that's given by the canadian
operations research society
anna's research focuses on networks
so it focuses on all types of networks
uh including uh transportation networks
logistical networks
financial social metrics and also the
topic of this top
of the the topic of this talk
which is a food supply
networks
during her talk i urge you to ask
questions by entering them in the
chat box uh on the right and at the end
she'll have the opportunity of answering
some of these questions and after the
session is over
anna will be available to meet you in a
virtual coffee break
on chime the link to this uh chime room
is in the
is in the program so anna thank you very
much for
accepting our invitation to give this
stock and i hope
everyone thank you
yes and i hope everyone enjoys i'm sure
i'm sure they will everyone who enjoys
this very interesting talk
so i think we can roll the video
greetings it's a pleasure to be speaking
to you today
it's a great honor i'm very very excited
to be sharing
our latest research related to food
supply chain networks
the title of my presentation today is
optimization of food supply chain
networks
why quality trade instruments and labor
all matter so i'll be giving you a
panoramic
view of the work that we have been doing
which i think
should be of great interest to all the
amazonians
i also would like to congratulate you i
think the theme
of this consumer science summit economic
decision making at scale is absolutely
perfect
so before i begin special thanks to the
organizing committee
of the 2020 amazon consumer science
summit for this information
and special thanks to my summit buddy
dr mauricio recende
i would be remiss also not to
acknowledge
uh whole foods in amazon pantry
which have been absolute lifesavers
during this covet 19 pandemic
the presentation that i'm giving today
is being dedicated
to all essential workers thank you so
very very much
so this is the outline of my
presentation i will begin with some
motivation
and some background and then i'll
discuss
how we capture quality in food supply
chain networks
we use an interdisciplinary approach i
think is very very relevant
because many consumers now really care
about their product quality
then i will transition to something
which maybe isn't getting as much
attention now in the pandemic but it's
also extremely relevant
and that has to do with different trade
instruments
and impacts i will
also be discussing some of our latest
research on
how one could incorporate labor and
labor disruptions
into supply chain networks and i would
be
specifically talking about the impacts
of
labor disruptions on food supply chain
networks from meat
to also fresh produce i will conclude my
presentation a discussion
of how we in operations research
operations management and analytics
are actually impacting policy now which
i think is extremely
gratifying so thank you for joining so
first some background i've always been
obsessed with
uh network systems in many different
kinds of configurations
from congested urban transportation
networks to complex supply chain
networks
we've even had several national science
foundation grants
to try and envision the internet which i
think is very very cool
and what we're interested in is modeling
the behavior of different decisions
decision makers and users on these
networks so we're interested in
also the underlying economics the
profits the flows
and so on so much of my research though
in the past 10 years or so has focused
on supply chain networks because you
have many interacting decision makers
there
they might have different uh criteria
that they seek to optimize so
these are really complex networks and
they're fascinating in terms of
applications
we've done work on energy networks a lot
of work in health care
and uh in addition disaster relief and
of course
in terms of food and that's the topic of
today's presentation
so i believe in writing books and
most of the books that i've actually
authored or co-authored
have a network theme for network
economics that was the first book i ever
wrote to fragile networks which i think
is extremely relevant now with all just
disruptions we're having in terms of
flows and even infrastructure issues
also i've written co-authored a book on
financial networks
and of course super networks and i'm
actually
the founding director of the virtual
center super networks at umass amherst
which i founded almost 19 years ago
just before 9 11. so the approach that
we take to food
is definitely multi-disciplinary and
i think what is really exciting about
this is we bring
say different scientific perspectives to
modeling
food and in general perishable products
supply chains
we bring in the physics the chemistry
the biology
so as i tell my students you know you
never know
what kinds of courses will be useful in
your research long term
so you should be studying as much as
possible
so to show that the work does get
recognized and noticed on
september 9th i was quoted in an
article in the new york times is a
two-page
article on food that was authored by
a pulitzer prize-winning journalist kim
severson
it got reprinted in the boston globe and
the quotes are being highlighted
in other publications so this is to say
that
the work that we do in academia does get
noticed and i'll be talking a little bit
about how to deal with the media
and so on to get the work out into the
public which i think is extremely
important now so what about quality
and food supply chain networks and some
might say
well how do we model quality you know
different products might have different
attributes different characteristics so
there is a lot of discussion
having to deal with you know how do you
capture quality
what is nice about food supply chain
networks
is that food scientists have actually
constructed all sorts of different
formula where you can measure how the
attribute of particular foods and
specifically
fresh produce actually decay
over time so that i think is so cool so
let me
get to this and also i think
uh in this copa 19 pandemic which was
declared by the world health
organization on march 11
2020 we're seeing the importance of food
okay sometimes you know uh we haven't
been able to get the meat that we want
we haven't we've been running out of
spaghetti uh and it's not just you know
the cleaning supplies but also it's
different kinds of food
products people are buying a lot of
oranges now they really care about
quality and health for their families
and themselves and also these fusafi
networks have suffered
you know major disruptions during the
pandemic
so when it comes to food supply chains
our work begins in 2013.
we actually published a paper in the
european journal
of operational research which was
recognized at a conference imposed in
poland
as being one of the most impactful uh
journal articles in that specific
journal published over
a couple of years so that was a great
honor
and what we have to realize is food
even in under the best circumstances
especially fresh produce dairy and meat
actually is always decreasing uh in
quality
over time okay so when you think about
you know supply chain network consisting
of you know
the producers the processors you know
the handlers the storage the freight
service uh provision
and so on uh you need to capture all
uh those very important network economic
activities and supply chain networks and
the
impacts on food quality so
what i think is so cool is that uh
with there are chemical formulae that we
can use which incorporate things
such as time temperature even humidity
okay so you can track the deterioration
in quality
over space and over time and
uh here we use differential equations
so for example if small q is quality
and you're interested in determining the
rate of
change of quality over time you use
different kinds of
factors we have a reaction rate which is
k
and we have what is known as the
arrhenius formula
so you have the temperature in there you
have the activation
energy and even the universal gas
constant
and you can see the rate of change of
quality over time
is equal to a factor equality raised to
the nth power
and different kinds of produce will
decay based upon you know the order
n so that is really interesting there
are some that
decay according to order zero
okay so you can see how the decay works
over time and there are others that
decay
exponentially so some of the actually
our favorite
produce now you know it's the summertime
and
north of the equator the peaches and
strawberries avocados decay
using a first order uh reaction
so what we did in our first paper
uh we constructed an oligopoly model
and where she had the firms competing
and
uh the consumers and much of our work
they care
about a product differentiation and they
care about quality
so in their demand price functions they
will respond not only in terms of
quantity
but also in terms of the quality okay
and in this paper uh we also were really
interested
in the profits the firms would get in
addition to the waste that would
propagate
so associated with different links in a
supply chain network of a particular
firm
you would have an arc multiplier and
as the food would move across the
different pathways
you would have a certain amount that
would actually
essentially decay and that would result
in waste so you would have a different
amount that would actually
arrive at the various demand points at
the demand markets
and the firms were interested in
maximizing profits that would
firms do in terms of sustainability and
also there would be a certain weight
associated
with waste minimization so that was our
first very general paper
associated with fresh produce food
supply chains and competition
then we went further with a former
student of mine now
professor and dr david spacek we decided
to focus on
farmers markets because i know there are
a lot of challenges and
i live in western massachusetts and we
wanted to see how we could incorporate
these
specific food signs formulate and
consumers then at the farmers markets
would be able to respond okay so
we collected data from local farmers
markets and low
local farmers as well and to see
how the quality would be impacted and
also the profits that
the various farmers would have and we
study disruptions
okay obviously farmers are subject to
the vagaries associated with weather
uh climate change uh droughts and so on
you know
frost so that was really important to be
able to study
the various disruptions and also what we
did then in a following uh
article we used as a strategic variable
not only the path flows that the farmers
the firms could choose but also the
initial qualities
so the greater the initial quality that
say
a food firm would invest in that would
propagate in a different way but there
of course would be an associated cost
and in this
model uh the consumers would respond to
the average quality because you might
have many different kinds of pathways
and that's what they would see
at the retail markets at the grocery
stores
and so on but again we deal with
differentiated products
so here we also have very general supply
chain networks and what it allows you to
do
is you can study what happens if you add
a demand market what happens if you add
you know another freight service
provider another storage unit
another warehouse and so on so uh once
you have
a really nice model and effective
algorithm
implemented in good code you can do
numerous sensitivity analysis
and that i think is the power of our
approach
okay so now uh once you do
a quite general framework to study
uh a product differentiation and
competition
in differentiated uh product markets
it's interesting always to see how the
work might be
related to different applications this
is something
you know practitioners love students
love and i love as well
so the other kinds of perishable
products that we have been doing a lot
of work on
are also a rise in health care
we work in pharmaceutical products where
you also have perishability
and now with you know hopefully a
vaccine
many vaccines against cope at 19 on the
horizon maybe more long-term than
short-term you know we're going to need
to have an effective cold chain
so this is very relevant and also in
this
model again it was like a generalized uh
supply chain network oligopoly model uh
we investigated the impacts of generic
competition and it reproduced actually
what was happening
in reality with the major pharmaceutical
farm
which was losing its patent rights which
i thought was really exciting
and this we allowed for direct shipments
because e-commerce is very
important uh people's you know need to
get their meds sometimes directly
delivered to their homes
okay also who would think that fast
fashion is a perishable product
but for many consumers that actually is
so we also have done work on fast
fashion where
in addition to the profits and objective
functions
um we substitute for example emission
reduction because
amazingly some fashion fashion firms
such as h
m actually do care about the environment
which is
also gratifying okay and then
finally i would like to emphasize uh
here we're doing optimization of the
whole supply chain network this was work
that we've done
that was inspired by the red cross which
was facing
a lot of challenges in the blood
services industry
so we were able to study uh
the supply chain network which is you
know quite complex there are different
kinds of tiers
and what's fascinating about this
application is a product you can't be
produced
you know uh you have to be willing to
donate
and obviously the covet pandemic a lot
of challenges associated with blood and
blood shortages
so now i would like to transition to
trade
instruments and impacts and also be
bringing in
quality issues and how trade instruments
actually
affect quality as well so
what we've seen in the pandemic vividly
illustrated
is uh you know how global in nature
many of our supply chain networks are
not only in terms of food but also
medical supplies for example ppe's we've
had major shortages you know
uh regional government states are
clamoring as well as healthcare
organizations and that's still
an issue now in september okay
so uh interestingly enough not only
historically but even for the past
couple years and now even more so when
it comes to the kova 19
pandemic uh there have been a lot of uh
trade instruments that have been
instituted by governments okay
typically no nation's government will
want to protect
its workers perhaps its consumers
okay but we'll be showing you the
ramifications in the impacts
uh who wins and who loses but it is a
highly competitive
global environment okay for many
different kinds of products so
here this is a very nice map i like this
having to do with the world's biggest
importers and you see china
is a huge importer of different kinds of
products as
is the united states but the kinds of
trade instruments that we've been
modeling and studying
and it brings you know the synthesis of
operations research
operations management with economics i
think in a very
nice way are the following we've been
doing a lot of work in terrace which
we've actually worked on for
20 years beginning with the dairy
industry a quotas and a combination
thereof which i'm going to share
with you a model which we developed
tariff rate quotas and they're kind of
unique and they're
kind of challenging to model but also
very very cool
uh before the pandemic almost every
single
day for months on end one of the top
stories on the first page of you know
new york times washington
post would be something on tariffs and
trade wars okay
it'd be the u.s uh imposing some sort of
tariff on some products coming from
china china would retaliate and it would
go
on and on so that's from uh just over a
year ago
okay a major headline in the new york
times
now this is something not so many are
aware of
okay there are quite a few countries now
uh globally that have instituted trade
instruments having to do not only with
medical supplies but also with food
in the kova 19 pandemic for example
we have the philippines have restricted
poultry imports from brazil
okay nigeria has restricted
imports of different food products then
you have
uh china reducing tariffs
on agricultural products and also on
certain meats because they're seeing
their consumers are suffering and
they've been a lot of issues with
shortages of pork there because of
different kinds of swine flu
and so on so you're seeing uh temporary
export measures
no restrictions of uh products the
countries are producing they're not
allowing them to flow out
and also a temporary import measure some
countries are
actually worried about different food
products actually bringing
in the disease i mean it hasn't been
really scientifically substantiated but
it makes sense okay that they would want
to protect
their populations their consumers i find
this absolutely fascinating
and there's a lot of uh also
policy uh instruments being implemented
on reducing tariffs
on important products for our country's
citizens
so you can see you know pharma part of
food and food
which you know not many people aware of
i feel that's really really interesting
so i believe that our research community
and also practitioners need to focus
more on constructing
computable operational mathematical
models
that allow policy makers you know
decision makers various governments
assess the impacts of different trade
instruments i think that's extremely
important and it's not just focusing on
the firms within
your nation but also what is the impact
on
consumers on you on me okay so this is
something i'll be discussing and it's
also very challenging
but rewarding research so this part of
the presentation
is based on the following paper
that we publish in the journal of global
optimization
and i'll be talking about tariff rate
quotas
okay and with application to
agricultural products
now what is interesting about tariff
rate quotas these are two-tiered tariffs
you have essentially a quota that is
imposed on a particular product
and a lower tariff if the shipments
in do not exceed that quota
on the other hand you're allowed to have
the imports exceed the quota but
associated with that will be
a higher terror and over quota so it's
kind of a stepwise function it's
interesting
and to you know you might not be aware
of this but the uruguay ran
in 1996 induced the creation of more
than 1
300 new trqs which is a lot
and the world's four most important food
crops rice sweet corn and bananas
have all been subject to tariff freight
photos so it definitely makes sense to
do research in this area
now uh there has been work done on
perfect competition
and tariff rate quotas using uh
typically a spatial price equilibrium
kind of framework so
that's something we have done a lot of
work on for many
years and our first tariff rate quota
in terms of kind of a spatial price
equilibrium
framework was a recent european internal
operation research paper
which we published in 2019
but now we're interested in
oligopolistic competition
because some of the food firms you know
they're big it's like agribusinesses so
uh we'd like to study the impacts and
what our framework allows one to do
is we're not limited uh to
you know specific functional forms we're
not
into just analytical solutions we have
the algorithms to compute solutions so
you can have nonlinear functions you can
have a lot of asymmetries you can have
interactions even very general demand
price functions and so on we think
that that's the power of our
methodological framework
so i'll be showing you a global supply
chain network model
okay where you can have firms in many
different countries and
uh the governments will be imposing
tariff rate quotas
and i'll discuss some of the highlights
and manager
insights that we've derived from a case
study
on avocados which is a very very popular
fruit now in the united states
and also in china because of its health
benefits
so you can see that i'm obsessed with
networks
this is uh the supply chain network
topology
for our model with trqs you have
different firms that are competing and
they have production sites in different
countries
and also their demand markets in
different countries
so here we identify different groups
so the government will say impose a
tariff rate quota
on say certain demand markets in their
country it could be all
and certain say producing firms in
different countries
and associated with each group will be
an under quota tariff tugg
and also an over quota tariff
so the strategic variables that the
firms have
is to identify these qihls
it will be the quantity of a particular
product
manufactured or produced by firm i at a
production site h
and then shift to demand market l for
consumption
and also here something that's very
important we have a certain uh
lagrange multiplier associated
with uh groups and kind of the quota
and that is in more economic language uh
denoting that quota rent equivalent for
a particular group
so what is the data that we use you have
certain production functions associated
with the production sites
that firms have you of course have
transportation cost
functions which is very important uh you
have conservation of flow equations and
demand price functions
and the demand uh say at a certain
demand market can depend upon the demand
for the products in the various demand
markets within the old region country
and maybe even
in other countries so what is the
utility
function say each firm say
i uh is interested
in maximizing its profits so you have
the revenue minus the total production
cost minus the total transportation cost
and then you have the certain term that
is added
which captures the under tariff
and if the firm goes above the quota
you capture uh in equilibrium
also that uh equivalent rent
a lagrange multiplier so you see
it's very very cool and then if you
don't have that
okay then you have just a standard kind
of utility maximization which has to do
with profits of a particular firm so
that would be a special case
so what is the definition this is a
nash equilibrium problem we have that
each firm wants to maximize its profits
to do as best as it possibly can
an associate also is another
set of equilibrium conditions which
captures
the over tariff quota and the under
tariff quota
so if you have say the shipments going
in
exceed the quota this will make sure
that
the tariff is actually incorporated into
the utility function
and if you don't have say for example
the shipments
are exceeding or needing
the strict quota for the group then the
price the
economic rent is actually equal to zero
and it works out very very elegantly
so the methodology we use for a lot of
our models
is that of the theory of variation
qualities
which is you can think of it as a
generalization of optimization theory
very useful for game theory and other
kinds of problems
so it allows under certain assumptions
for us to formulate very general
equilibrium conditions
as a single e inequality which is known
as a variation
inequality so you see that here we have
uh the marginal utility functions with
respect to the
uh the strategic variables and also we
have
an additional term uh which has to do
with the
quota and the economic rank equivalence
so we're interested in analyzing this
problem
and and getting the solutions and if you
don't have trqs
then it collapses uh the formulation
to this very nice and elegant uh
variation quality formulation which is
just in the product loads of strategic
variables
so also this model has a special cases
you might just have unit tariffs
which makes sense and also
we can handle strict quotas in which
case uh
the nash equilibrium conditions because
you know you can't exceed the strict
quota
uh becomes a generalized nash
equilibrium problem
which is also very very cool and unless
of many other applications you might
have different decision makers competing
you know for scarce resources so they
have common constraints they have shared
constraints so the nash equilibrium
concept
is no longer sufficient but you need a
generalization to a generalized nash
equilibrium concept
so we did a case study in this paper
having to deal
with avocados and
mexico is a big supplier and also
china and there's been a trade war in
this
market and very interestingly that
now the volume of uh
avocados consumed in the u.s has
amazingly surpassed
surpass the volume of bananas so
this is i think that's pretty cool and
you see again front page of the new york
times there were tariffs imposed
on uh this very very popular nutritious
products so i think this is
also many hipsters you know millennials
uh they love that guacamole so
terrorists are coming for your guacamole
okay
so uh what we found in our analyses
is well first in terms of literature
there's not much work that has been done
in terms of imperfectly competitive
firms
and supply chain networks and trqs
uh the various quality framework is very
elegant both theoretically and
computationally
and uh we were able to do you know many
different kinds of scenario
uh analyses which you know look at our
paper
but the thing is what is what happens to
consumers well
our results demonstrate unequivocally
trqs can be effective in reducing
product flows from countries in which uh
on which they are
imposed okay but that at the expense of
a consumers
in terms of prices so uh governments
will be protecting their firms okay
they're producers but consumers are
suffering and this keeps on coming
over and over again i'll show you the
impacts on quality
okay so then we'd be again to
investigate
what about if you have quality also as a
strategic variable
uh can we do some analyses of you know
the impacts of trade policies
on quality and also profits of firms so
we published a paper last year in
transportation research e and there we
investigated tariffs
or strict quotas on consumer welfare
okay so what is the impact on consumers
so again we had a supply chain network
topology
and uh what we found that
first of all there's a really nice
equivalence
between imposing a strict quota and
also tariffs if the strict quota is
tight
and you have that lagrange multiplier be
a corresponding tariff you will get the
same product flows in the solution
as well as the same product quality so
this is kind of
neat okay uh it's pretty clear
you know that governments would prefer
tariffs to strict quotas
because they get the income then from
the terrorists but still it gives
governments the flexibility of doing
one or the other okay and then we did a
case study on soybeans that's also a
very
important product for china for the u.s
especially for our farmers
and china has been a great importer of
soybeans because of its rapidly
increasing population size
and the u.s actually is a big exporter
but also because
of the tariffs and the trade war
associated with this product
we had other countries in south america
brazil and argentina actually gaining
more of the market which was
really really interesting and in this
study we did all sorts of analyses
focusing on major firms
in the u.s who are exporters of soybeans
and this is the power of our methodology
you can
do sensitivity analysis you know
infinite number of possibilities which
is good
but you know the punchline from the
consumer's perspective results
consistently
and unanimously show consumer welfare
declines for consumers in the country
imposing a strict quota or tariff on the
imported product
okay so we're really arguing for free
trade
hence a government may wish to loosen a
quota and quickly reduce a tariff so
it's not to adversely affect
its own consumers especially during
the pandemic okay now producing firms
what they really should do
on these competitive supply chain
networks they should
expand the demand markets within their
own countries
and that's been happening uh that's very
effective you know very basic kind of
redesign of the supply chain network
under a tariff or quota and it results
in higher profits for firms
also firms should expand number of
production sites to countries which
aren't subject to these
and as some are doing in the us going to
mexico for example
so they are more resilient when it comes
to such
trade policy instruments in governments
we can see that the terrorists might
still continue
okay and quotas but clearly governments
they prefer tariffs because of the
financial benefits that they can get
the impacts on trade flows can be
substantial
so other work that we've done on quality
is you know what if you know firms
actually want to compete
in terms of supply chain network quality
and there you have quality in terms of
perishable products non-perishable
products
also quality in terms of freight service
provision which is something
really important because you don't want
your perishables
deteriorating during the transportation
process
and here we identify all sorts of
different network topologies
uh even when it comes to you know
multi-tier supply chain networks
and we have measures of performance
which is very important in this day and
age
if say how do you identify which is the
most important supplier
in your supply chain network how do you
identify and rank
may be the freight service providers
okay because those are the ones you
should invest in
if you knock out a particular supplier
it might have major ramifications
uh to your profits and to the very
viability of your supply chain network
so this is a book which was a finalist
for a major
uh prize in europe we didn't get it but
it was still a great honor
to be nominated consider so
now let me transition to something which
we've been working on very very intently
during the pentagon
and here what we're doing is really
integrating kind of
economics again and operations research
operations
management to focus on general supply
chain networks but with inclusion of
labor
this is something that has been
dramatically illustrated
in the pandemic what happens if you have
insufficient labor what happens if the
labor is not as productive because they
might be getting
ill okay some of them are actually
perishing
and ramifications throughout the supply
chain network so let me show you what
we've been doing
and we were inspired because of
you know the losses in the suffering
and also the importance you know
essential workers and importance of all
us having healthy food and nutrition
since we battled this pandemic
so some of the most vivid news i think
the dramatic news
was the number of illnesses in meat
processing plants i mean processors tend
to be you know it's an oligopoly
and uh if something happens you know to
one of the four major meat processors
and many of them were getting shut down
you can see that you know
we are having meat shortages in terms of
beef chicken
uh and also pork the prices are rising
they continue to rise today and that
happened even in the
organic chicken market which i thought
was really interesting
and also i should mention it's not just
a matter in terms of meat processing
that we've seen major disruptions in
this coca-19 pandemic
but also in terms of fresh produce
and processing many of the workers that
do the harvesting
are migrant workers some of them have
been getting really ill
and as they're moving up the northeast
you know from florida all the way up to
maine and even on the west coast
we're seeing major shortages
in terms of labor now specifically maine
for blueberry picking
and it's horrible when you think you
know there's so much food insecurity in
the u.s
in other parts of the world but still
farmers had to
call their animals and what could be
more painful for farmers
and not to mention all the economic
losses
okay also uh because the difficulty of
transportation and so forth and actually
the migrant workers moving
from other countries from mexico for
example to the us
and this is global in nature okay even
in europe
uh it's hard to get sufficient volume of
labor
to do the harvesting now okay also
we are seeing complete you know
disruption
supply chain networks having to do with
food because you know the business is
closed the
school's closed restaurants closed and
so on
so we really have to re-envision
redesign our food supply chain networks
and also uh recently the new york times
in sunday magazine section had
a full themed issue
focusing on food insecurity and hunger
which is
really really painful to see something
needs to be done about this so
uh the news about the food disruptions
it was not only national in scope but it
was
international scopes so we just got our
adrenaline going and folk as it said
let's study this so the first paper
that i wrote uh incorporating
labor into general supply chain networks
focused on
perishable food supply chain networks in
the code pandemic
and it's a paper which is uh coming out
in a book that i'm
co-editing with my colleagues uh elias
good sirius
and panos pardallos this is the third in
a series that we've co-edited
together focusing on dynamics of
disasters
impact risk and resilience and solutions
and uh what we're dealing with in the
copa 19 pandemic
is a major health care disaster
so lack of availability of labor is one
of the drivers
of supply chain disruptions if you don't
have labor
to harvest if you don't have labor to do
the processing
no these are critical links and supply
chain networks you're not going to have
the food moving from the originals to
the destination notes
and you might have a complete disruption
like a closing of a plant
or you might have say a reduction in
capacity because you don't have enough
labor
so this is something we were interested
in studying
and also we're seeing even in our
community you know farmers are kind of
trying to sell more directly
to consumers obviously amazon has been
brilliant with
electronic commerce so we
have in our supply chain network this
perishable food one
also direct links going from say
production harvesting
sites to points of demand right they
could be for example
grocery stores or they could be
say you and i are homes that are being
directly supplied with
nourishing food but you see uh this can
be
quite complicated it depends on
the particular food product that you're
working on
and here we also handle the
perishability as we did
in the first paper which i discussed
with you today
the european journal was published in
european journal of operational
research but we incorporated labor in
the following eye
okay we had associated with each link in
the supply chain network a certain
capacity of labor
and using kind of economic production
functions
we were able to map the availability of
labor
into the production in terms of flow
in a particular link and associated with
each link would also be a productivity
factor because we think that's really
important you know
there might be some workers who you know
for various
reasons might not be as productive in
this stressful period now
okay so how would that affect the prices
you know the profits of the firms and
the availability of the products to the
uh consumers and also as i mentioned we
wanted to
uh avail ourselves of uh being able to
analyze direct sales whether
farmers markets nearby farm stands you
know
or even directly to consumers
so what we found in our analyses
uh which i think is really interesting
that you might have in a supply chain
network a disruption even in a single
link
such as a freight one and that might
significantly negatively impact our food
firms
it's really important to do these
studies in terms of resilience okay
because these are the ones you should be
protecting
also preserving productivity and all
utilize supply chain network economic
activities is critical
since the impact of a drastic reduction
in productivity can also severely reduce
profits
okay direct sales is very very helpful
to maintain or even enhance productivity
and that makes sense
you know because the pathways are
shorter you're dealing with shorter
supply chain paths and there's less
likely
to be a disruption
also the cost can be lower okay in
addition a firm
should be enhancing its marketing that's
really important
online marketing um so consumers
are willing to pay you know a higher
price you know they
might be more aware of the quality that
you're providing
and major profit increases can occur
so now we began uh to go further
and said okay that was for an
optimization model
firm having control over its partial
product supply chain network
what happens when there are firms now
competing for labor which is happening
in uh you know many sectors of the
economy uh because we have labor uh
shortages uh mentioning in terms of
migrant workers in terms of production
of ppe's
and so on so we did a game
theory extension of the model that i
kind of just
highlighted and uh there we were able
to incorporate different kinds of labor
constraints which i thought was
really really interesting and the
application that we focused on was on
migrant workers and the harvesting of
fresh fresh produce so here we have
multiple firms
that are competing you know
they have a differentiated product but
it's substitutable
and we consider three different kinds of
labor constraints
in the first kind of labor constraint it
was as in the previous model
we would have bounds of labor on
specific
links okay so that was kind of most
restricted
labor was allowed to move and then we
considered well
let's suppose we have uh say a fixed
amount of
labor associated with a tear so
labor can move say from different
production sites for example
but still the firms are competing for
that fixed amount of labor
and that could also be the case for
freight service provision from storage
and so on
and then finally we had kind of the most
flexible labor constraint we would have
a single bound of labor
in the supply chain network economy and
labor could move
across firms and across economic
activities
okay obviously there could be some costs
associated with that but we see that
that's actually happening in some
countries for example in scandinavia
like sas for example has laid off a lot
of its airline employees
but they're being retrained to work as
healthcare workers
okay so this is something that we
thought was really really interesting so
here i've highlighted
you know the three different scenarios
and
in the case of the first set that
becomes
uh of constraints a uh classical kind of
nash equilibrium problem
but in the case of the second constraint
when firms are competing for a fixed
amount of labor cost of tier
uh that becomes again a generalized nash
equilibrium and
obviously when you have a single labor
constraint and labor can move across
you know the different activities that
also you know they share
a common constraint okay so they're
competing not only through their utility
functions but also through the
constraints because it's common
and this is interesting that third set
of labor uh
the consulting company mckinsey uh
recently noted
that you know they are kind of
recommending this kind of free mobility
of labor but obviously there are costs
you know some people might not be
willing to but if you want employment
this might be definitely the way to go
okay and that can help in terms of
supply chain effectiveness
while also re-envisioning and
reinforming
uh reforming our supply chain network so
we did
a lot of numerical examples documenting
potential
impacts of labor disruptions under these
scenarios
uh we study disruptions and
manufacturing plans storage facilities
which is happening folks uh what happens
if you add another competitor what
happens to the demand price functions
uh are affected and also
the impacts of labor disruptions
decrease of labor you can also do
obviously
increase so i've mentioned you know the
methodological
equilibrium concept so let me now
highlight how we have and this
is really gratifying impacted policy
through
analytics so i really
believe that and this takes a different
mindset that if you do
you know a couple of major research
studies and publications
one needs to get the news out to the
public you know to different
audiences because then the policy makers
are more likely to see
the results of your research and perhaps
you can actually
influence policies so i've been doing a
lot of
writing i would say for the last oh
i would say definitely five six seven
years of op-eds letters to the editor
and so on i'm a big proponent of writing
for the conversation because then your
articles
can be reprinted in other media sources
which is really good
and that usually leads to invitations to
be
on television to speak on radio programs
and you can further disseminate the
results of your studies
and i enjoyed that okay so on march 11
2020 as i mentioned
before the world health organization
declared the pandemic
on march 12th i published uh an
article on blood supply chains that's a
perishable product supply chain
that is also related to food okay and
health care
in the conversation and uh an extension
of it
also was an invited piece by informs
in his analytics coronavirus chronicles
and the thing is many uh countries over
the
uh around the world starting with china
iran
where coronavirus cova 19 hit before it
really
came to the united states they were all
suffering from flight shortages
and that that's a big big issue so i
wrote this piece
and um then it followed up
with you know additional uh media
articles
i talked about food because it's related
nbc news in boston
usa today salon the verge and one of my
favorite ones was to be on a radio show
in fargo north dakota and there i spoke
actually to farmers on various shortages
so what happened hey what's the
punchline here well
on april 22nd 2020 uh there was
a letter written and you can see it
online
uh from the california attorney general
this iran to admiral brett gerard who's
the assistant secretary of the use
department of health and human services
and it was signed by uh u.s attorney
generals of 21 other states
including in my very own state of
massachusetts
saying that you know something needs to
be done we think
that some of the restrictions in terms
of blood donations
uh discriminate and other some of the
restrictions
need to be reduced so my article in the
conversation
which was reprinted in life science
was the first citation in this document
so i think uh this is a great honor
a great tribute to the kind of work that
we do in operations research
and analytics and we continue to do so
you see
some of the signatories okay so
with this uh presentation i'd like to
thank you
uh we'll be posting the slides from this
presentation online on the virtual
center for super networks
and there you can find uh many other
of our publications our lectures
so i hope you come to visit us and i'm
very much looking forward to the
discussions
and the qna and thank you so much and
thanks for amazon
for all the great work from your
researchers and
uh how you keep us you know
healthy and supplied with food and many
other important products
thank you